je vous demande d'accueillir à présent
le président de notre famille politique
député de Nice je vous demande
d'accueillir Éric
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cioti mes
amis mes
amis chers
compagnons ce rassemblement cette
réunion
ce moment exceptionnel voulu par les
jeunes de notre famille
politique autour de guilemme carillon
fera date
oui depuis
Valence pas simplement parce que nous
nous trouvons cher Nicolas dans une
ville admirablement
gérée
dirigé avec efficacité et
talent simplement parce que nous nous
trouvons dans une région qui a bien des
égards marque une exemplarité une
réussite tout à la fois mêlé par des
racines historiques et par un cap tourné
par vers
l'avenir mais ce moment qui nous réunit
à à Valence fera
date parce que à cet instant Laurent
vquier
a fixé un cap a tracé un chemin et ce
chemin je veux le lui dire nous voulons
le suivre derrière
[Applaudissements]
lui Laurent ton discours il était
attendu il était
espéré
nous
mesurons toi et moi la sincérité de
certains conseils
désintéressés qui invite à modifier le
rythme qui invite à prendre des chemins
qui ne peuvent nous conduire que dans
des
impasses le calendrier tuz le
maître les idées les valeurs nous les
coniss non pas par déclamation mais
parce que tu les as toujours défendu là
où tu as siégé là où tu as
bénéficié comme ici dans cette région
verneuronalpe de la confiance des
électeurs la seule qui vaille la seule
qui oblige la seule qui guide alors oui
aujourd'hui ton propos il nous fait du
bien et il nous donne encore plus de
force ce moment ce discours à Valence
c'est celui de
l'espérance d'abord parce que la
jeunesse est une
espérance vous êtes cette espérance vous
êtes l'espérance de la France vous êtes
une jeunesse qui croit vous êtes une
jeunesse qui pense vous êtes une
jeunesse qui a bien des égards aller
dessiné c'est lendemain d'une France que
nous voyons aujourd'hui dangereusement
sombré alors oui pour moi Valence
rythmera ce tempo et rimera avec
espérance
ensemble mes amis nous devons pierre
après pierre bâtir cette
espérance je vous ai fait une promesse
l'année dernière lorsque j'ai porté ma
candidature à la tête de notre famille
politique après la déroute que nous
avons subi à l'élection
présidentielle après ne plus avoir gagné
une élection
nationale depuis 2007 Laurent le rappelé
c'est de vous conduire à la
victoire de vous conduire à la victoire
en
alors je n'ignore pas les difficultés du
moment je n'ignore pas les choses
trappes les embûches les
arrière-penser je vois nos
adversaires qui dissimulent mal leur
caractère de prédation nous regarder
comme une proie qui ne resterait qu'à
avaler
je vois de chaque
côté les appels non pas à l'Union à
l'unité de je ne sais quelle formation
politique mais
simplement le regard à vide de ceux qui
n'espèrent qu'une chose nous absorber
nous diluer nous faire disparaître et
bien aujourd'hui plus que jamais vous
dites nous disons que nous som là que
nous sommes debout et que nous allons
gagner en
[Applaudissements]
2027 exprimer cela ce n'est pas faire
preuve d'aveuglement
d'inconscience
naturellement je mesure comme vous les
de notre famille politique celle qu'elle
a connu je mesure comme vous l'ampleur
de la tâche de redressement
auquelle nous avons tous la
responsabilité dans l'unité de
participer mais je mesure plus encore la
dégradation de la situation de notre
pays belle jeunesse de France belle
jeunesse des
républicains vous êtes certes des
militants des militants de notre famille
politique vous êtes pour la plupart né
avec ce siècle un
siècle où aucun des dangers des menaces
ne vous aura été
épargné l'angoisse migratoire l'angoisse
sanitaire l'angoisse climatique
l'angoisse de la
guerre mais oui cette jeunesse cette
belle jeunesse animée par nos valeurs
puisée au fond de notre histoire
elle regarde aussi avec desespéran la
situation de notre
pays nous sommes engagés
dangereusement sur la pente mortelle du
déclin et du
déclassement Bruno rotaillot François
Xavier bami an jeunevard tout à l'heure
le rappeler
oui notre pays est menacé oui notre pays
est menacé deil
oui notre pays est menacé dans son
existence même nos modes de vie nos
modes de vie occidentaux aujourd'hui
sont attaqués par une immigration et par
un communautarisme qui nous menace oui
notre avenir est menacé quand nous
voyons le
classement dans l'échelle des grandes
nations régresser d'année en année
nous ne sommes plus que la 9e nation au
monde pourtant nous avons éclairé par
nos pensées par nos résultat par la
science par Le Progrès le
monde et ce déclin nous le mesurons nous
le mesurons quand nous voyons au plan
économique que nous sommes tout à la
fois le pays où nous dépensons le plus
d'argent public et où nous payons le
plus d'impôts où chaque année nous
gagnons la Coupe du Monde des impôts
nous voulons bien entendu gagner la
coupe du monde de rugby comme nous avons
à deux reprises gagné la Coupe du monde
de football mais la Coupe du Monde des
impôts nous voulons la laisser à
d'autres nous voyons aussi le poison de
cette endettement Bruno en a souvent
parlé qui aujourd'hui porte en lui les
germes de la disparition de notre
nation nous dépenserons au cours de
l'année
2023 plus de 55 milliards d'euros pour
rembourser notre
dette au rythme actuel où évoluent les
taux d'intérêt ce montant
àissal atteindra quasiment 90 milliards
d'euros en
2027 c'est-à-dire mes amis deux fois
quasiment le budget de notre défense
national quatre fois le budget du
ministère de l'Intérieur et neu fois le
budget de la justice voilà la réalité la
dette pour beaucoup elle est tellement
énorme elle est tellement virtuelle mais
la dette c'est une hypothèque sur
l'avenir et la dette c'est une injustice
profonde vers la jeunesse de notre pays
c'est une inégalité majeure qui
s'installe parce que c'est vous qui
demain Pirez cette dette qui a été
creusée par les générations
d'aujourd'hui avec
irresponsabilité et avec
dangerosité clin s'incarne aussi lorsque
la sécurité de nos concitoyens et donc
leur liberté à se déplacer à se mouvoir
partout jour et nuit sur tous les
territoires n'est plus garanti n'est
plus assuré n'est plus respecté
oui notre liberté n'est plus au cœur de
notre pacte républicain quand ceux qui
avec courage ont fait vocation de nous
protéger et je veux leur rendre hommage
nos policiers nos gendarmes nos pompiers
nos
militaires deviennent eux-mêmes des
cibles quand ceux qui nous protègent ne
sont plus protégés alors plus rien ne
tient quand l'on voit que nous sommes au
45e assassinat à Marseille depuis le
début de l'année quand nous mesurons
qu'il y a à peine quelques mois dans
notre pays plus de 300 écoles ont été
incendiées plus de 500 bâtiments publics
ont été détruits que des façades de
mairie ont été carbonisées que 900
policiers et gendarmes ont été blessés
alors qu'ils ont été les gardes fous
contre les menaces qui pesaient sur la
République oui nous mesurons combien
aujourd'hui notre République est en
danger alors dans ce contexte vous avez
mes amis vous avez derrière guilem parce
que vous formez cette force vous portez
cet enthousiasme vous incarnez ces
valeurs vous avez une
responsabilité plus que tout autre pour
redresser cette France qui sombre
aujourd'hui c'est à vous que les mains
de l'avenir ce sont dans vos mains que
l'avenir de notre nation est aujourd'hui
inscrit
oui nous avons tout à la fois cette
responsabilité individuelle de tout
donner à la nation que nous aimons en
retour et en récompense de ce qu'elle
nous a apporté de son histoire de sa
grandeur de ses lumières mais nous avons
aussi l'immense devoir l'immense devoir
de dire la vérité aux Français d'ouvrir
cette route route d'ouvrir ce chemin
dans la fidélité à des valeurs des
valeurs qui défendent notre identité
notre histoire notre culture nos modes
de vie qui disent avec force que nous
sommes les héritiers d'une grande
civilisation judéo-chrétienne et que
nous ne voulons pas qu'elle disparaisse
des valeurs qui portent la liberté la
liberté qui est notre bien le plus cher
et quand cette jeunesse est là elle
porte ce message de liberté nous voulons
aussi porter cette valeur d'autorité
d'autorité dont nous avons tant besoin
l'autorité qui protège la société de la
loi du plus fort l'autorité qui protège
la société de la loi des bandes de la
loi de ceux qui placent leurs conviction
leurs croyan leur appartenance
religieuse au-dessus des valeurs de la
République cela à cela nous leur disons
qu'ils ne gagneront jamais en France
parce que vous êtes là et parce que vous
voulez vrai contre ces menaces et contre
ces dangers
alors
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est une route
qui
s'ouvre notre responsabilité la mienne à
la tête de notre famille politique et de
poser sur ces routes sur cette route sur
ce chemin qui doit nous conduire et
c'est l'objectif ne le perdons pas de
vue et lions à chaque seconde cette
ambition à la victoire en 2027 et une
victoire
elle se construit elle se
bâtit je veux dire à ceux qui regardent
notre famille
politique comme n'ayant que pour seul
destin leur ralliment à ceux qui soit
ont fait effondraer la France ou soit la
conduirit dans un habîme encore plus
fort notre seule place la seule qui
vaille la seule digne de notre héritage
et notamment celui que nous a légué le
général de Gaulle notre seule place
c'est la
première oui notre destin c'est de
retrouver cette première place non pas
par ambition non pas par
satisfaction bien sûr que cela nous
guide nous anime et nous donne de la
force mais tout simplement pour servir
la France pour lui donner le meilleur de
nous-mêmes pour enrayer sa chute pour
servir de pyon de rappel alors que cette
cordée dont on nous parlait en 2017 se
transforme aujourd'hui dans un dangereux
dévissage sur cette falaise et vers cet
abîme qui a l'impression de nous aspirer
de façon inéluctable
oui notre famille politique doit être
indépendante elle doit être indépendante
parce qu'elle est forte parce qu'elle a
cet héritage parce que vous êtes là
parce qu'elle est la première force
politique en terme de militant parce
qu'elle est la première force politique
en terme de territoire avec les maires
avec les élus départementaux avec les
élus régionaux avec nos sénateurs qui
ont remporté Bruno avec Gérard Larché
une magnifique victoire dimanche dernier
qui nous donne la majorité au Sénat de
la
République
parce que notre famille politique doit
être
aussi celle des idées celle du
projet j'annoncerai demain une
réorganisation de notre famille
politique qui donnera encore plus de
place à nos idées à nos valeurs je veux
que les républicains deviennent le parti
des idées je veux demain Laurent le
rappeler que notre famille politique
deviennent celles de la baisse des
impôts nous avons des objectifs de
politique publique à installer pour cela
il faut travailler réfléchir débattre
être innovant dans un monde qui bouge
qui n'est plus le même que celui que
nous avons connu qui doit prendre en
compte de nouvelles aspirations
notamment en matière de travail
notamment en matière de défi climatique
en notamment en matière d'intelligence
artificielle nous VO voyons bien que
notre monde est à un tournant il faut
savoir appréhender ce tournant il faut
savoir il apporter des réponses nous le
ferons par les idées nous le ferons par
le projet et nous allons y travailler
avec force le parti de la baisse des
impôts le parti de l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé qui
embrasse beaucoup de perspectives nous
ne sommes pas les comptables de ou tel
chiffre nous sommes les artisans du
redressement d'une ambition collective
où chacun trouvera sa place dans une
société plus juste dans une société qui
promet et qui promut le talent le mérite
qui récompense l'effort dire que nous
voulons demain l'augmentation de
l'espérance de vie c'est bien sûr
répondre par la science au défis
climatiques c'est bien sûr répondre par
l'humanité au défi de la dépendance
c'est bien sûr cher Yannick ner répondre
au défis d'une meilleure santé face à un
système qui s'effondre c'est tout cela
qui nit nous guider alors que nous
mesurons des inégalités qui s'installent
comment pouvons-nous accepter qu'entre
les grandes métropoles de notre
territoire et les plus petits villages
de nos zones rurales il y a un écart
d'espérance de vie de 2 ans
aujourd'hui cette inégalité elle n'est
pas acceptable merci à Laurent d'avoir
porté hier ce grand projet pour
l'égalité des territoires pour le
respect du monde rural en refusant
notamment cette approche technocratique
qui s'incarne dans ces acronymes qui
sont les zones de zéro artificialisation
nette qui sont dans les DPE qui sont
dans cette accumulation de normes
technocr
qui ne risque que de déconstruire notre
pays sans jamais le protéger voilà mes
amis tous les défis qui s'annoncent
voilà tous les défis qui sont devant
nous en 1 an nous avons beaucoup
travaillé merci à guilemme merci à
Nicolas merci à Laurent de l'avoir
appelé merci merci à Annie Genevard
notre secrétaire général à nos
parlementaires qui sont ici Valérie
Boyer Stéphane piénoir à Emmanuel
Antoine député de laadome à François
Xavier Bellami à Yann Boucard à
geoffroid Didier ici aussi à notre à
notre sénateur Gilbert boucher que je
salue avec avec amitié qui est là
aujourd'hui
oui nous avons
travaillé et je veux je veux remercier
du fond du cœur Bruno rotaillo nous
avons été
[Applaudissements]
concurrents nous avons été concurrents
l'anniversaire l'année dernière mais
nous n'avons jamais été adversairire
tellement nos idées sont communes vous
avez aller quasiment à parité fait un
choix mais en tout cas je veux dire à
Bruno combien je suis heureux est porter
cet esprit d'unité dans notre famille
politique et c'est essentiel qu'on soit
aujourd'hui uni
rassembler aucune
force aucune force ne doit être absente
tellement les défis sont majeurs quement
la tâche est grande oui nous avons porté
l'école de formation George Mandel le
média une certaine idée un
contregouvernement
oui euh nous avons avancé grâce à
l'unité entre l'Assemblée nationale et
euh le Sénat sur la question et la
réponse migratoire qui est sans doute le
défi le plus lourd qui est posé devant
nous et devant les jeunes générations
oui nous avons pris nos responsabilités
et je le dis et je le revendique sur la
question des retraites n'avoir pas eu
cette attitude aurait été une agression
vis-à-vis des jeunes générations qui
aurait eu à payer le prix de nos
inconsistences oui tout cela nous
l'avons fait tout cela nous continuerons
à le faire mais les défis les défis sont
les plus sont encore plus plus lourds
encore plus immenses avec notre histoire
avec nos valeurs avec vous avec la force
des jeunes républicains et merci à
guilem de lui avoir donné cette
impulsion nous relèverons ces
[Applaudissements]
défis nous les relèverons ensemble nous
les relèverons dans la dans la fidélité
à nos valeurs et bien entendu Bruno
François Xavier vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure en ayant aussi le courage parce
que c'est l'honneur de la politique de
penser à nos frères d'Arménie à ce
pays dont nous
avons tellement avec lequel nous avons
tellement le point
commun pour dire à l'Europe qu'il faut
qu'elle sorte de sa lâcheté pour
défendre aujourd'hui le peuple arménien
dire que nous devons rompre toute
relation diplomatique avec
l'Azerbaïjan que nous devons installer
des sanctions très fortes que nous
devons prendre des initiatives beaucoup
plus fortes devant le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies c'est le
devoir de la France c'est le devoir de
notre famille politique de le dire de
l'exprimer avec force parce que cela
participe aussi de l'honneur de la
politique et de la grandeur du une
nation que nous voulons voir demain
retrouver la première place au service
de valeurs qui ont fait qui ont fait et
qui ont forgé ce que nous sommes qui
nous donne une place une mission si
singulière si spécifique celle de
construire et celle de relever la France
que nous
[Applaudissements]
aimons
descend
alleztintin
[Musique]